visite guidée ce matin à la cité des
sciences et des techniques de la ville
est dont une partie ouvrira ses portes
au public le 14 mars prochain et l'autre
partie à l'automne 86 lorsque cette cité
sera terminée elle constituera un
ensemble unique au monde qui viendra
compléter aux plantes parisien les
richesses du conservatoire national des
arts et métiers et celle du palais de la
découverte auront molinero il était une
fois un musée de la connaissance
coincé entre l'arc de triomphe et le
bisc une maison ouverte à tous où l'on
apprenait son subventions presque à
apprendre un palais de la découverte où
tous les muséologues du monde continuent
d'ailleurs de venir pour dénicher son
secret regardez ne suffit pas il faut
comprendre
il est vrai que l'on en sort un peu plus
lourd de connaissances le monde y est
divisé en discipline physique ou
biologie et l'on peut y faire des
expériences
alors quelle différence avec cette
nouvelle cité des sciences et de
l'industrie
et surtout pourquoi ces sept niveaux sur
3 ha qui ont déjà coûté plus de 4
milliards de francs
et si loin la villette sur le lieu même
des anciens abattoirs
en ce concerne le palais de la
découverte nous avons déjà commencé à
collaborer avec lui il faut bien savoir
que le public qui va dans ce genre
d'endroit n'est pas un public constant
que chaque nouvel équipement attire un
public nouveau qui bénéficie aux autres
n'oublions pas par exemple que le musée
d'art moderne de la ville de paris a vu
son public augmenter énormément après
l'inauguration du centre pompidou
donc vous pensez faire une fertilisation
croisée avec elle elle a couvert tout à
fait avec une approche assez différente
mais complémentaire
vous pensez qu'ils auront des crédits à
la hauteur des autres
je ne sais pas si à quelle hauteur on
peut parler mais ça c'est un problème
qui concerne le palais de la découverte
et son ministère de tutelle
je pense que le contenu a été fait avec
naturellement beaucoup de scientifiques
et aussi beaucoup d'industries au total
entre 2500 et 3000 personnes pourront
travailler à réaliser le contenu
d'exposition permanent choisi sur quels
critères
c'est moi qui ai choisi un musée c'est
d'abord l'oeuvre d'un homme un homme qui
a choisi mars 86 pour ouvrir la moitié
des expositions permanentes plus une
médiathèque de 150 mille volumes pour
commencer et à peine et arioi fans
inauguration septembre avec une
présentation par thème et non plus par
discipline de la terre à l'univers par
exemple ou laventure de l'aide les
espaces marie curie des vallées de
particules en pagaille pour l'instant un
festival de béton et de gravats très
beau la lumière entre rafle hausse est
prévue et l'ont tour à la cité comme une
promesse de vie mais suffit-il de
s'appeler hall diderot pour refaire en
dur l'encyclopédie du 21e siècle